in the last video we estimated the
solution to e to the x is equal to 1
over x times x minus 1 times x minus 2
using a calculator we got a first rough
estimate by just looking at this graph
and then we tried values out to really
zero in on or get close to the x value
where this is true what i now want to do
is actually just use the graphic the
graphing functionality of this
calculator to try to estimate the
solution graphically so let's go to
graph and what i'm going to try to do is
graph both of these functions so the
first function let me clear this the
first one is e of x which in this on the
graphing calculator will be y1 and
that's going to be
e
to the
x power
and then the second one
the second one y two will be r of x
which is going to be one
divided by
x
times x minus one
minus 1
times
times x minus 2
x
minus 2
and so let's see i have to close this
parentheses as well so i've entered in
the graph and i also want to i care
about where we zoom in so i immediately
want to zoom into this part of the graph
right over here so let me go to the
range
so
actually there's also a zoom
functionality that i could use but let's
let's actually let me let me do that
that that could be fun so let's let's
just let's just graph it
actually let's just see what range it's
graphed at right now let's see what we
would care about let's start with kind
of a
rough approximation just to see that
this is indeed the same graph so let's
start with
x going from zero up to i don't know to
three
so this would be this part of the graph
right over here and then the x scale is
one that's what they'll mark off every
one we could even mark off every 0.5 if
we want like this one is marked off
every 0.5 and the y minimum let's go
from 0
to well this range actually goes pretty
high and the way this is graphed it goes
all the way up to
looks like 10 so i'll do 10. i'll leave
the y scale as one they mark it off
every one right over here and now let's
graph this thing
and
that was e of x and now it's graphing
r of x and you see it indeed looks
pretty similar to what we have here now
what we care about is this point or on
our calculator this point right over
here we want to figure out what x value
what is the x coordinate of this point
of intersection this is when our two
functions are equal to each other so let
me
zoom in
on this
so let me i think i can use this box
function functionality so it essentially
lets me construct a box
around this and it's going to zoom into
that box so i'm going to get as tight in
on this as i can go
so if i press i can get even tighter on
it
so if i press enter now i can define the
other corner of the box
so that's pretty good i'm going to zoom
in press enter and that's zoomed in onto
that little teeny box so that was e of x
and now it's going to graph r of x so
now let me try to trace the graph
so
let's see trace so it's letting me trace
e of x
and let's see if i look at my x values
decrease so at this point e of x is
still higher than r of x and if we get
right over here
so at 2.056
we see that r of x is above we see that
r of x is above e of x we just see that
graphically and then we're left to we're
left with the point of intersection
and then we're still left of the point
of intersection now we're right of the
point of intersection so it looks like
the point of intersection is between two
point zero five seven and 2.059
and so in the previous video when we
said it was well where our estimate was
2.06 we were definitely within one we
were definitely within 0.01 of the point
of intersection if we did want to get
even more precise we could
we we could zoom in more and i encourage
you if you've got a graphing calculator
like this to to actually try that out